bitte teilen wichtig eilmeldung corona
virus pandemie außer kontrolle
ein gezüchtetes virus behauptungen wie
diese geistern derzeit durchs netz aber
was davon stimmt
das virus wurde im labor gezüchtet
unsinn
wir wissen dass coronaviren immer wieder
von tieren auf menschen übergehen können
man kann überhaupt nicht davon ausgehen
dass das jetzt ein virus ist aus einem
labor oder ein neu generiertes virus aus
dem labor das ist da gibt es überhaupt
keine hinweise für und wie gesagt so ein
plötzliches auftreten ist was was wir
von den corona während canon faktencheck
mit susanne herold die seit jahren zu
coronaviren forscht am uniklinikum
gießen und andré wolf vom faktencheck
portal mimi kammer
das virus kann nur mit eigener
körperkraft bekämpft werden ärzte sind
machtlos
es gibt derzeit keinen impfstoff das
stimmt so weit aber die symptome können
ganz normal natürlich behandelt werden
das heißt wenn jemand infiziert ist wird
diese person natürlich im krankenhaus
behandelt die symptome werden
entsprechend behandelt also auch da
betreibt das video reine panikmache
das neue corona virus ist weitaus
gefährlicher als das sars virus von 2003
also das los hat einige ähnlichkeit mit
dem sars virus das wissen wir es ist
aber nicht gleich dem saas virus und man
kann deshalb auch schon gar nicht sagen
dass es wie roländer ist als des sars
virus denn wir wissen jetzt aus den
letalität zahlen aus dem todesfall
zahlen dass die deutlich geringer ist im
vergleich zu dem saas virus beim
jetzigen kurios zur wahrheit gehört zwar
auf das sich weltweit schon mehr
menschen infiziert haben
als 2003 bei der atemwegserkrankung saß
aber grundsätzlich ist das eine form der
gezielten panikmacher eine form der
stabilisierung wir haben das in der
vergangenheit schon häufiger beobachten
können es geht hier nicht allein und das
corona virus sondern in der
vergangenheit waren es dann mal
terroranschläge amokläufe die verwendet
wurden um gezielte falschmeldungen
gezielt verschwörungstheorien im umlauf
zu bringen die das ziel haben bestehende
systeme ein staat staatliche systeme zu
diskreditieren und zu schwächen
grund zur panik gibt es nicht sagen
unsere experten umso schädlicher seien
solche videos
[Musik]